Emilio is with us in Ohio hi Emilio how
are you hi Dave I'm good in you better
than I deserve what's up so here's my
situation I am a graduate student in
physics I have about a year left to get
my PhD and I make around after taxes
around $22,000 and projected to make
about a hundred thousand and when I
graduate good I have had some student
debt it's about thirty thousand dollars
and I do have some credit cards of four
or five thousand dollars so here's my
question I'm actively in that and I
shouldn't go in anymore good but I am
planning to propose to my girlfriend
three year oh yeah
we're also planning to go on a on a
short trip during the summer so combine
these two probably be adding $4,000 to
my debt so my question is so my plan is
to pay for this using credit card with
some promotions of zero interest rate
and the idea is that I'll graduate and
I'll increase my income before the
interest increases or essentially I'll
be able to pay them off with no interest
and my question is if my judgment here
is good or bad where do you recommend
they do bad it's a dumb idea you're
deeply in debt already you don't need to
go further in debt you can't afford to
go on a trip you're broke right now if
you want to get her a $1,000 ring and
you save up and pay cash for that and
get engaged I don't have an issue with
that but you don't need to be traveling
around the world man you're deeply in
debt and broke when you get out of debt
you can do that right so the like the
way my I'm making excuses in my head is
you are and like right so for example
major many people might say like I don't
have money now but Emilio if you want to
do it go do it
you asked me what I thought I think it's
a
really dumb idea I wouldn't do it yeah
okay you can you can rationalize your
butt off the rest of your life but at
the end of day you are in debt because
you keep buying things that you don't
have the money for and at some point son
you got to stop that you need to stop it
pay cash for things or don't do them and
don't go on trips when you're in debt
you don't need to be doing this stuff
it's just not wise and so you guys are
you know you're him she's gonna be just
fine my wife got married with a thousand
dollar ring on her finger and she has a
headlight on her finger now so it'll
work out there is no correlation between
the size of the ring or the quality of
the engagement trip and the future
marriage being successful none
whatsoever
that is not what causes marriage success
so that you know no I would not do that
but you're gonna do it but I wouldn't do
it thanks for the call